hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his sermon number nine Joseph Butler
towards the end is going to try to shift
our perspective on anger and resentment
and forgiveness and love of enemies into
an explicitly Christian context that
that is one informed by scripture and
thinking about things in terms of the
human beings relation to God not
exclusively of course as we're going to
see but certainly you could say
predominantly and the first thing that
we should look at is where he uses Jesus
Christ as an example and a very extreme
example Christ is on the cross being
crucified and says father forgive them
for they know not what they do and what
does Butler take this to
emblemize or signify for us forgiveness
and a forgiveness that is
extraordinarily vast those who are
killing God God's self whatever himself
are being asked to be forgiven by the
the one who is suffering
and he says that though injury and
Justice oppression the baseness of
ingratitude are the natural objects of
indignation or if you please of
resentment they are likewise the objects
of compassion and so Christ is like the
primary example of that but he's saying
that we can do that too how can we do
that
well we can look at the people who are
engaging in these offenses that he just
rattled off and say yes those are bad to
other people they shouldn't be doing
them but they are even more
damaging to the wrong doers themselves
he says no one ever did a designed
injury to another designed injury one
that is intentional
but at the same time he did a much
greater to himself if therefore we could
consider things justly such a person is
according to the natural course of our
factions an object of compassion as well
as displeasure doesn't mean that we
can't look at them and be like that
person really shouldn't behave that way
but we can also say all that poor
miserable bastard thinking that is a
good way for them to behave and so this
is why he brings up Christ on the cross
saying father forgive them for they know
not what they do if they didn't know
what they were doing they wouldn't be
doing the bad things that they are doing
and so we can show compassion he also
tells us something very interesting here
I think this is a very suggestive idea
he says the offenses which we are all
guilty of against God
and the injuries which men do to each
other are often mentioned together and
what he means here is that in scriptural
passages whether in you know the Jewish
scriptures or in the Christian New
Testament these are often being brought
up in relation to each other often in
the same line or set of lines what's
going on there why is there a connection
between our own misdeeds towards God and
what it is that we dumb human beings do
to each other well he goes out and he
says
making allowance for the infinite
distance between the Majesty of heaven
and a frail mortal and likewise for this
that he cannot possibly be affected or
moved as we are that's God right
offenses committed by others against
ourselves and the manner in which we are
apt to be affected with them give a real
occasion for calling to our mind our own
sins against God now you know God
doesn't according to Butler get angry
with us in the same way that we get
ticked off with other people
but if we think about how other people
do things to us and the anger that we
feel we could be like oh man I let God
down all the time I'm I'm not a good
person in the respect that iof and
pretend to be and he says that
um this is a very important point there
is an apprehension and presentment
natural to mankind that we ourselves
shall at one time or another be dealt
with as we deal with others
and then he talks about
the this peculiar acquiescence in and
feeling of the equity and Justice of
this equal distribution so what's he
getting at there
when we think about our own viewpoints
our own attitudes our own responses to
people wronging us and the anger that we
feel and then whether we actually
continue to exhibit benevolence love you
know forgiveness Mercy compassion
towards them or whether we push that
aside
we are saying this is the way that
people should behave we're also saying
God should behave that way to us God
will behave that way to us that's
actually one of the things that gets
stressed in scriptures we will be dealt
with
as we dealt with others
and so he brings up some biblical
passages he talks about the book of
sirach a
deuterocanonical work uh written by you
know sirach and Alexandria he says he
that Revenge shall find Vengeance from
the Lord and He will surely keep his
sins in remembrance forgive your
neighbor the hurt he's done to you so
that your sins also will be forgiven
When you pray
one man Bears hatred against another and
he seeks pardon from the Lord he shows
no mercy to a man who is like himself
and he asks forgiveness for his own sins
so he's saying there this is you know a
uh earlier Christian and not Christian
uh uh Jewish text that gets used by
Christians it's often called
ecclesiasticus because it was read so
often in the Ecclesia in the churches
if you want to be forgiven by God you
better be forgiving to other people
because otherwise God is going to treat
you the same way that you're treating
other people
um he goes on and he says
um
let anyone read our savior's parable of
the king who took account of his
servants this is in Matthew right and
the equity and lightness of the sentence
which was passed on him who is
unmercible to his fellow servant will be
felt what is he referencing there so you
know there's a person who is in debt and
uh and then he goes to another servant
and he's like give me my money right and
well if you act that way if you don't
forgive other people their deaths your
debts are not going to be forgiven
either that's that's a bit of a problem
there
so he says there is somewhat in human
nature which Accords to and falls with
that method of determination
so let's place before our eyes the time
which is represented in the parable
what is being talked about there he says
our own death the final judgment
so we can imagine ourselves being judged
by God and if you do that and you're
being honest with yourself
well you know if you're a forgiving
person he says that could actually be
you know quite a positive experience for
you he says a good man in the same
circumstance and the last part and close
of his life conscious of many frailties
as the best are but conscious too that
he had been Meek forgiving and merciful
that he had in Simplicity of heartburn
ready to pass over offenses against
himself having Felt This Good Spirit
will give him not only a full view of
the amiableness the lovableness of it
but the surest hope that he will meet
with it in his judge so if you are a
forgiving person if you do let things
slide if you do get angry but don't sin
because of that anger you can expect
that you are going to be treated
likewise by God who's going to say well
you screwed up a good bit but we'll let
it pass
what if you're not like that what if
you're a grudge holder what if you're a
person who counts up the offenses of
others he says
suppose yourself under the apprehensions
of approaching death that you were just
going to appear naked and without
disguise now that naked without disguise
so you can't conceal anything from the
just judge all the lies that you told
other people that you half believe in
yourself
you're not going to have those to hide
behind anymore
all the excuses that you've made all of
the you know prioritizing preferencing
yourself saying oh it's okay for me
that's not going to slide
what happens then he says
um if you have to give an account of
your behavior towards your fellow
creatures could anything raise more
Dreadful apprehensions of that judgment
than this
the reflection that you had been
implacable that is unappeasable unable
to be made peaceful and without Mercy
towards those who defended you without
that forgiving Spirit towards others
which that it may now be exercised
towards yourself is your only hope I
mean you better hope that God is more
merciful than you because if you're the
model and God is going to treat you the
way that you treated others you're
screwed so you know those are some
considerations he says
um if you forgive men your their
trespasses your heavenly father will
likewise forgive you and he says so that
we might have a constant sense of it on
our mind the condition is expressed in
our daily prayer what is he talking
about the Our Father where you say
forgive us our trespasses and then how
does the line go as we forgive those who
trespass against us that as we
pretty important there what if you don't
forgive those who trespass against you
well when you ask forgive us our
trespasses as we forgive those who
trespass against you you're in effect
saying don't forgive my trespasses
because I don't forgive anybody else
right you're that's the as that is being
preserved there so if we reflect on this
according to you know Joseph Butler this
will put some things into perspective
about the commands to forgive injuries
and love enemies we're not being
commanded to do anything that's beyond
our capacities and it's a way of like
participating within you could say an
economy in which forgiveness is
distributed to us just as much as we
distribute it to other people or
actually even more because God puts up
with more of our BS than we put up of
other people's BS according to Butler
and so he says a forgiving spirit is
therefore absolutely necessary as ever
we hope for pardon of our own sins as
ever we hope for Peace of Mind in our
dying moments or for the Divine Mercy at
the day when we shall most stand in need
of it and this is how he ends his sermon
nine with these Reflections offering
them to his audience and to us his
readers